daha önce de kendimden kısa bir şekilde
bahsetmek istiyorum basketbol ve
İstanbul'da başladı mezar ve Spor Kulübü
O zaman şimdiki Levent lerimizi
civarındaydı birçok okullardan seçmelere
alıyorlardı Ben seçilmemiştir aslında
seçmelere girdim istediğim birşey
yapamamıştım başlamıştım ama o kadar çok
istemiştim ki antrenörüm bana kırmızı
şort icinde Ben de kırmızı çok vardık
seçilen arkadaşımda da ben de o anda
Koşarak gittim Sen seçilmediği dediler
bana Üzüldüğüm için iyi sen de başla
dedikten sonra ki bir basketbol
Kariyerim var yani şansa dayalı mı desem
kısmet mi desem öyle bir durumumuz oldu
Ondan sonra sırasıyla tabi Efes Pilsen
ayaklarını Kombassan Konyaspor
Galatasaray
a b c d erdemirspor gibi profesyonel
seviyede basketbol hayatım oldu
basketbolun Bana da neler kattığını
anlatmak istedim ama bunu şöyle
anlatacağım size buradaki profesyonel
bir basketbol anlayışından dolayı bunu
anlatmıyor Bu benim için böyle olabilir
Ama herhangi bir çocuk için şu anda
hedeflenen seviyede olmayabilir ama
önemli olan basketbol kültürü devam
ettirilmesi Hayat şekilde git o yüzden
basketbol bizim için çok önceki şunu
söylemek istiyorum basketbol oynamak
için çok disiplinli ve çok zeki olmak
zorundasınız ikisi birleşmeli Bu da
ilahi hayatınızı çok fazla bayağı
geçiyor Çok çalışıyorsunuz Çok emek
veriyorsunuz Emeğin karşılığını almaya
öğreniyorsunuz Sonuçta hayatta
biliyorsunuz değil mi Ben de her zaman
bu örneği diğer sporcu arkadaşlarıma
öğrencilerime bağlı aktarmaya çalıştım
önemli olan
Bu ketbol da beraber bir hayat şekli
yaratmaktı bir insan hayatında her zaman
spor olmalı kesinlikle olmalı Ben
basketbol telefonu anlatırken size üç
tane olabilirsiniz bir basketbol
hayatınızdaki hayatınızda eşdeğer
tatlılar bulacağına emin olabilirsin
neden takım çalışması hayata bakış
sosyalleşme basında çok ciddi size diğer
rakiplerine göre bir ön atabilir
ikincisi disiplinli olmak zorunda
olduğunuzu bildiğiniz için antrenman
disiplini maaş disiplini birbirinize
olan saygı ve sevgiden kaynaklanan
disipline olduğunuz için bir sonraki İş
hayatınızda üniversite hayatından
sonraki her türlü alanda başarılı
olmanızı çok ciddi seviyede destek
olacaktır üçüncüsü mutlu olmayı ve
üzülmeyi seviyorsunuz acı tektir
üzüldünüz hata olduğunu Evet ben hata
yaptım ya kaybettik Ama olsun yeniden
başarmaya çalışmak gibi çok önemli 3.
günahsız
çok istiyorum çok önemli çocuklar
başarılı olmak için üç tane çok önemli
do ne var belirlenmiş olur mu bu başarı
dedim sadece basketbola bir hayat olarak
da olabilir bunu lütfen gözardı etmeyin
bir kesendere kesilmediğini olmazsınız
iki sakın çalışması inanıp takım
çalışmasına beraber gitmişsiniz O yüzden
Basketboldan ciddi var üçüncüde a
hayatta her zaman yaşayabileceğimiz
düşmeler kalkmalar başarılar başarısız
hepsinde yeniden hayata güven ve
mutlulukla bakabileceğiniz bir spor
dalıdır Aslında basketbol biz bu
taraftan başlamalıyız Şimdi siz idare
çok güzel yerlere geleceksiniz çoktan
aşıldı alanlarda başarı elde edeceksiniz
oyna Bunu yaparken bunu yaparken
kendiniz başardınız şeyin mutluluğunun
çok daha fazla şey yok
o Cihan duyuyor musunuz beni diyorsunuz
iyi şu anda Evet hocam sesimiz geliyorum
devam ediyorum Şimdi öncelikle neden
basketbol oynamalıyız mantıklı bir
saçının kardeşi var değil mi genç mesela
Orada Alperen de var galiba şimdi acelen
ne bizim Hadi başlangıcımız ilkokul 3.
sınıf galiba hatırlamıyorum Onunla
beraber çok güzel bir yola Gittik
Beraber gittiğimiz oy oldu arkadaş
süslemeye geldi basketbol olarak
şampiyonluklar yaşadı hayata bakış açısı
ile ilgili çok büyük katkıları oldu
basketboluna aslında ben burada
anlatırken çok güzel örnekler var Bak
sen bizde berabersin İki senedir neler
yaşıyoruz nelerdir nelerle ADR ediyoruz
Nasıl olsa çok iyi biliyoruz O yüzden
ve en büyük tavsiyem çocuklar şu
Basketbolu bir hayat şekli hale
getirmelisiniz zorlanmayı sevmelisiniz
Hayat zaten çok kolay diyorsunuz O
yüzden de zorlanıp çalışabiliyor sanız
sonunda gerçekten Emek verdiğim her işin
karşılığı muhakkak alacağının basketbol
İşte bu ne saat disiplinini Beşiktaş'ın
basketbol cacık Sesim geliyor değil mi
bilmiyorum Evet o yüzden de herhangi bir
spor Dalını seçebilirsiniz ama
basketbolun Sır Vereceğim Bana göre ben
o işte hayatım boyunca olma geçtiği için
Kendimle gurur duyuyor O yüzden size
Bence sizde kesinlikle bir spor dalıyla
beraber ulaşmalısınız buraya şekli hale
getirmeniz basketbolcu oluruz olmayız
önemli olan
Bu gerçekten Basketbolu Hayat şekli
halinde de büyüdüğünüzde çocuklarız
olduğunda hala basketbol oynamaya devam
ettiğiniz bir hayalimiz var boyu puan
çocuklar her zaman ve her zaman farklı
olurlar eşsiz o taraftan bakabilirsiniz
şimdi bu soru-cevap bir şeyle
dönebiliriz istiyorsunuz Sonuçta
basketbolun her şeyi konuşuruz canım Sen
istiyorsan soruları bana geçebilirsiniz
Bence soruları cevaplayabilirim merak
ettiğiniz bir şeyler varsa onları
konuşabiliriz canım canemre Nisan
arkadaşımız var Neden mesleği seçtiğini
Soruyor yani işte aslında bu mesleği
seçmem Şimdi profesyonel seviyesine
geçmeye başlamakla oldu Kolay bir
tercihiydi Universal devam edebilecek mi
sistem ama bu işi gerçekten çok zor yani
üst seviye yapabilmek için çok ciddi
emekler vermek zorundasınız herhalde Ben
ona çok hazırdım
çok istiyordum yani yapmak istiyordum ve
başarmak istiyordum ama ne kadar
başarılı başardığınızda gibi durum değil
ama herhalde ben o anda o tercih
fotoğraf yan yana kullandım e şanslıydım
eli seviyelerde oynadım A Milli Takım
demiş Ha Samet yakında oynamadım altyapı
takımlarında oynadım önemli değil
sonuçta bir seviye basketbol hayatının
oldu Bunun kararını o anda akıp gelen
bir durumla ilgili
değerlendirebilirsiniz ama ben tercihimi
okula beraber yapmaya Çalışsak da
Basketbolu bir meslek haline getirmek
için kendi istediğin çok ön planda
olduğunu düşünüyorum Başka var mı Onu
sormak isteyenler istedim 50'lik kaldı
sonra açacağım Aynen öyle yapalım merak
ettiğiniz her şey de sorabilirsin çok da
güzel bir sohbet olabilir Ben de
arkadaşların görmüş olurum heyecanlı ve
güzel bir şekilde sohbet etmiş oluruz
olur mu Çok sürekli kendim bir şey
iyi Basketbolu anlatmak istediği kadar
iyi Ondan sonraki şey oluyor Yani
kendini anlatıyormuş gibi oluyor Ben çok
seviyorum normalde biliyorsun koşullara
karşı da söyleyebilirim var mı Soru
anlatmaya devam edeceğim ben şimdi Cihan
sana bir soru sormak istiyorum ben
soracağım sana tamam mı Ben neden
Basketbolu seçtin ve basketbolun sana
olan getirin edersen ne düşünüyorsun
basketbolla ilgili Basketbolu Hani
alemde birçok kişi basketbol oynadığı
için seçtim basketbol Gecesi Show Hani
atıyorum bir konferansta bana Özgan
verdi önemli su arkadaşlarımla Hani daha
birbirimize bağlantı olduk Çünkü aynı
ortama çıkıp ter döküyorsun kesinlikle
üzülür
Bu ortama anne normal telefon bilgisayar
öğrenmek gibi dedi yani Omuz Omuza
birlikte mücadele verdiğin için daha bir
anlamlı oluyor şu kesinlikle en çok iyi
arkadaş en çok Bir rakip olmayı
öğreniyorsun Aslında değil mi yani
gençlere vermek istedim tavsiye var mı
mı ya gençler vermek istediğimiz tavsiye
olarak Bence siz çok fazla öyle
söyleyeyim size
bu çünkü gerçekten mükemmel gidiyorsunuz
sizden çok mutluyuz açıkçası bizim
90'lar iyi arada kuşaklar öyle zor
dönemler görüyorsunuz yani şimdi kaçıncı
yüzyıldayız nerelerdeyiz yorum ya ha
Bence her çocuğum kesinlikle bir kesinti
spor yapması lazım Spor yapmak basketbol
yürüyüş ve bir kültür olarak kendi
haline getirmek Sonuçta Anneler de bugün
Aslında görmedim yani şöyle anne babalar
spor yapıp örnek olmalılar spor yapmayan
bir ailede çok fazla sporcu çocuklar
geçme şansı yok Türkiye'deki
eksiklerimiz Aslında bunlardan spor
hayatın her yerinden Bence nüfuz etme
kesinlikle Özgür Cihan benim sorunlar
demiş hoca
Az önce ve Alperen Ben Siz basketbol et
hoşluk olarak Koçluk yapmaya Basketbolu
bıraktıktan sonra hoşluk yapmaya yapmayı
niye tercih ettiniz şöyle arkaya anjum
Burada da hayatın ve insanların neler
getirdiği inanın çok enteresan belli
olmuyor Ben basketbol biraz erken
bıraktım Ondan sonra işte kendimle
ilgili sporcu bir sonraki hayatımı
Aslında onunla ilgili birkaç
düşüncelerim vardı antrenörlük yapmak
işte sporla devam edebileceğiniz bir şey
hayatımı yaptığı bir meslek burada
basketbol oynamaktı o basket boyadıktan
sonra farklı bir bir dalga geçmek çok
tehlikeli aslında hani ben ona
söylemedim demektir İşte yaptığım şey
daha yapmaya çalışmayın çok severim
Antalya olmaya karar verdim Aydın'a
geldik Spor Kulübü kurdu
çok farklı taraflara geldik şimdi daha
güzel değil mi ama diyorum ya sana bu
basketbolcu olmakla devamlılık sağlayan
bir şey aslında yani çok fazla bir
basketbolcu çoğu antrenör Menajer olur
bildir hazır vazgeçer ama şimdi
Araştırmadan şu anda farklı işle uğraşan
ve başarılı olan oyunlar çok yoktur
mesela burada Emre ağabeyiniz var bizde
beraber şu anda Efes Pilsen de beraber
oynadık çok iyi bir oyuncuydu o şu anda
farklı bir şey yapıyorum şimdi çok
başarılılar Bu da birçok iyi bir şey
alalım çok seviyede o iş yapmaya
çalışmış o yapamaz çok insan var çünkü
profesyonel hayata sadece basketbol
ibadetiyle farklı bir sosyal Çevrenizde
hayata bakış açınızı olmalı bence
eantrenör olmaya karar verdim Spor
Kulübü Hayal ediyorduk spor okulları ile
ilgili bu taraftan çalıştım Hatta
Bu şarkı çocuklarından bırakalım yani
ben de basketbolun türlü başladığımda ki
ilk çocuklarından dır Alperen Bence iyi
şeyler yaptığımı düşünüyorum şu anda
celasun Hadi neredesin iki sene üst üste
şampiyon oldular bir sürü gruplara
gittiler Aydın'ı temsil ettiler işi
yapmak çok keyifli başardığını görmek
çok keyifli antrenör divancı en güzel
şey şu çocuklar sıfırdan bir şey
yaratıyorsunuz altyapı olarak söyleyeyim
de sıfırdan bir şey aratırken bir
çocuğun neler başarabileceğini
görüyorsunuz ve onu yönlendiriyorsunuz
ve bu yönlerde içerisine katkınız oluyor
o harika bir duygu bazen basketbol
oynamaktan çok daha değerli oldu
istediğin bir şey var mı bir durum yok
ama dediğim gibi mücadele etmek
basketbolun sebeple diye düşünüyorum
çocuklar siz de bence bu yolda
bu basketbolla kalın İlla oynamak değil
iyi bir televizyon spor izleyicisi olmak
da bence çok güzel bir şey basketbol
gizlerken keyif alıyorsanız ne mutlu
bize sizin size bir şeyler vermişiz
demektir Ama dediğim gibi bana bu şansı
verdiğin için çok teşekkür ederim cihaz
için teşekkür ederim hocam iyi akşamlar
iyi akşamlar bu